[Music]
so the patent system has been a great
driver of medical inventions we've seen
some terrific discoveries and inventions
in the medical space but as we've as as
we've evolved in the system I think
we've we're starting to see as a lawyer
who's practiced in this area we're
starting to see a lot of strategies that
are played by pharmaceutical companies
in order to maintain them an optic hold
or their exclusivity hold over a
particular product and what they do is
they ratchet up a number of patents
around a particular product in order to
prevent competition from getting in and
we all know that once you have
competition prices drive down as a
number of studies that show prices can
drop well below 50 but more than 50% if
you get competition in the marketplace
sooner so the idea that companies want
to do is is to basically prevent that
competition from coming up in earlier
and also it and then the other argument
of that is is are they then really
inventing new things because what they
do is they hold on to the marketplace as
long as they can on the existing product
they extend the franchiser
by using patents sometimes with the
potential of holding the market for 40
years
unless litigated and we all know that
litigation doesn't solve all the
problems and we've seen that in a number
of the top-selling drugs in the United
States we've done studies as an
organization where we have seen price
hikes between 2012 and 2016 on the top
12 selling drugs in the United States of
68 percent and we've seen in in parallel
to that the number of patents that have
been stacked up on those products even
after the products being approved even
after the initial initial patent has
expired which is a 20-year term and so
they're just pushing it out further and
further and further so that they can
delay the competition getting in and
that all leads to market power and it
all leads to the ability to increase
prices at will I believe that there are
there are there are differences between
if you look at a pharmaceutical company
the scientists who work there
the people who work on the development
of drugs their primary purpose is to
help people I believe I've generally
believed that I believe they the
conversations I've had with people from
that sector they they believe that if
they bring a new product to mark and
save someone's life or it can actually
make somebody healthy they really do
believe that unfortunately there's a
business side to it as well and so what
you have is for every scientists you
have probably two lawyers who are
watching over them saying okay how can
we extract a patent out of this and to
make sure that nobody else gets in there
and so what we have is then you have the
particular pharmaceutical market there's
an argument that it's become overly
financialized in terms of its investors
who drive what companies do rather than
then the maybe the initially intended
prints purpose was to deliver health
products and to help make people not
have to become ill and and stay alive
and I think a lot of some of that has
got lost in the process as the pumps
have cook up is down really start to
look at their bottom line in their
shareholders and what the investors want
rather than what their original purpose
was was to help people become healthier
and I think that the bargain of that has
tilted more towards the financialization
of things rather than thinking about
health first I'm at comprises lawyers
and scientists who've come from the
private practice background we've all
worked in industry I myself have been a
solicitor in the United Kingdom working
for the commercial side of intellectual
property for over ten years and we've
taken that knowledge to apply it in a
public interest way whereby we look at
particularly the drug in the
pharmaceutical industry how do
pharmaceutical corporations strategize
their patent filings in order to get the
maximum protection so what we do is we
we look at a product it could even be
still in development and we'll do that
we'll do what we call the due diligence
and the analysis of all their patent
filings so for example if it's a pata if
it's a product that revolves around a
small chemical compare
we'll identify what that chemical
structure is and then what we'll do is
we do pattern searches there various
databases that you can use we put in
keywords we will use a compound searches
and then we'll find out what it is that
the company is filed for and then we
track how many other patents that the
company is adding on in the lifetime of
the product and that way we build up a
sense of what is their entire portfolio
around that particular product and that
then gives us a sense of what their
strategy is what potentially is the new
version of the product that they're
maybe lining up so that what they do is
typically products these days in the
pharmaceutical market they're on the
market for five years and then they'll
switch it out to the next version of the
product and these patterns usually tell
you what's coming down the line then and
we use that essentially then to make
decisions and often at the behest of
organizations such as Doctors Without
Borders who want to get access to these
products but they say you know the
patents are a barrier the prices are too
high and then we'll investigate the
science behind them as we're doing these
analysis and what we realize is some as
many times that the science behind her
it's not new and then at that point we
decide whether we want to challenge
those patterns in order to remove the
barriers so that competition get in
earlier and by doing that then we lower
the we get generic competition in
earlier if we're successful and prices
dropped significantly and we've achieved
that in in various ways for example in
India we've been very successful with
the HIV drug collector which was a
product owned by Abbott Laboratories now
AB V and we were able to challenge the
key patents on their drug and such that
Abbott eventually withdrew all this
patent applications and Indian generic
companies could continue to supply this
particular product at a much lower price
not only to Indian patients but also
many patients around the world and
particularly in Africa and so we were
able to keep that market at a much
accessible way for for people living
with HIV AIDS and that for us has been
one of the greatest successes but more
recently we've done it for the new
hepatitis C drugs for example just this
year we got a decision in the drug
the drug by Gillian Cole sofosbuvir we
were able to win a case in China and
China has ten million people living with
hepatitis C and the fact that we won
these two cases in China now has the
potential of other actors to come in and
supply the Chinese market which could
save conservatively if you were just a
treat 15 percent of the the people
living with hepatitis D in China that
would save thirteen billion dollars so
overall our impact of our work has the
potential of saving 1 billion dollars to
the various countries that are need to
be able to get access to these drugs
[Music]